the one who bit me it was an ambush I
never saw right I was too lazy to look
behind me but if I would have seen him
coming I've had alligators go after me
and at the last minute I get alone a
water and I grab him by the chin that
tilt her head up and that disrupts her
attack it confuses the alligator and
usually do that a couple times it'll
work the attack I had one tried to take
me down ten times before I mean I get a
left of water and then it'll stop but as
long as I was there he kept coming
around he tried to go in under water at
me on a surface different styles of
attack it was able to block him every
single time on the attack by grabbing
you got to make sure you don't put your
hand in his mouth when he's coming at
you at the last minute you gotta grab
that skin down there I mean don't go try
this on your own
I won't yeah I'm not going unless you're
there you do this also in your boat
broke down and you're swimming and you
got attacked and the last resort it's
great I know something like that yeah
definitely don't I'm not telling you to
go look for these it's kind of like you
know I took karate lessons I'm gonna go
to a bar and pick a fight somebody will
beat your butt or you might get shot in
the head right something like is there a
video we can see of you of you
levitating an alligator I'm sure that
one that's yeah that's probably the
largest alligator ever in my life Wow
where's this egg is this one it's a 13
foot plus I had alligator expert look at
me in a video and everything I'm talking
about him I was on my way home we were
filming you know just whatever we could
find fish yeah Gators anything you know
to do a good you know nature show right
the way is this in Florida yes yeah
there's a lot of hydrilla in this area
okay the hydrilla a lot of times the
water is clear but what a hydrilla does
is it covers everything is like a spongy
jungle right and you know look see the
alligators and all kinds of animals can
disappear into the hydrilla right and it
grows off the bottom yeah it comes out
the bottom that's about 25 feet at the
bottom of the canal well I can't move
how clear it is yeah I drill that thing
clears water
okay oh [ __ ] see your kisses back so
that means he's he's pissed well he's
not going the other way he's come in our
direction
yeah so instead of okay leaving he's
interested
yeah he's headed right to us oh [ __ ]
at this time I was already lost my
finger in my left hand
oh really yeah oh my God he's huge
I do another good lift on him too I
really show him well though yes you saw
a slow motion yeah
was that thing like a thousand pounds I
said a thousand pounds it's it's a
massive animal there's a lot of fish in
that area
so now he doesn't want to be messed with
now he's like [ __ ] that I'm gonna sleep
no no he's gonna lay down there okay I
mean I'll go down and pet him and
everything I throw the budget man I
can't even was I I do a thing where I
grabbed him by the scoots and I let him
off though off the bottom gently okay
and he's so heavy I can't
I clearly jump me I can't even grip him
get a grip on him yeah I lost my fins
like that I need to get me a new pair of
those body board fish yeah I know boogie
board fins that's what the cold I you
don't get them and I shop you gotta go
to a search yeah yeah I found out the
best thing to use out there's not those
long free diving finish or one for
maneuvering around alligators and sharks
you want that yep you want the short
ones I'm not into the going deep now I'm
into their messin with the animals so I
don't need the lungs in you have no
traction with it right I got a ghulam
get out of there beside I can't get in
front of him he's facing the bank and I
don't have any room you know and you
couldn't pull them out you have you stay
on you have to stay under under his jaw
under his head you don't want to be
directly here because that's what he's
gonna jump up and get you okay I like to
get below him
that's place to be with an alligator is
underneath em here okay his eyes are
above his head see yep see how little
the eye looks compared to the spot that
tells you how big that alligator is
things are moose because what happens is
the head will grow the size of the eye
really yeah alligators got a either
looks like a frog yeah pops out it's big
yeah tiny little head with two big eyes
on it it looks like a frog and then when
it grows you know that I see the yeah
yeah because it's still a big eye but
the head that's how big he is that was
so much bigger
she's darker now yeah yeah he's already
uh freaking out so he's gonna dive into
the hydrilla forest he said I found the
wrong human defenses to this
see what was going on over here
[ __ ] minifigs over here I do want to
listen and then I leave them alone I
don't want to stress modern everybody my
dad he's gonna come back at you okay and
you know I'm not I'm just interacting
and I really you know hunting the
alligator side yeah no need to that is a
price Gator I get like that is already
bread dough I saw him and he's I think
he's over here it was so big
did we saw two different spots I found
where the tail was and quite a found
with where the head was really so I got
it's a big mound of hydrilla so I'm
gonna go in I got to go inside the
hydrilla not to look for man oh my god
now watch when I bring him straight up
I'm gonna put him in tonic immobility
and mobility okay so you're just going
into the the plants whatever they're
called oh my god that's my left hand
right there look how big that head is
holy [ __ ] now right and see how he looks
more calm yes right now the head is
straight up this is kicks in tonic
immobility now he just hit a surface now
he explodes and then I took him up and
he started tilt his head back it went
off like a stick of dynamite and I
thought I quit there let's forget it
yeah look at that thing that think
there's dinosaur that's what it looks
like it looks like a dinosaur he's
running along the bank watching
[Music]
Wow I bet you were safer underwater than
you were on the bank right I was just
thinking about what if this Gator guts
right they want you they'll get you
under water above alligators hunt on the
water okay
people don't know that they do they'll
sit in the bottom of the mouth open
waiting to come nearby and hunt oh
really
and I also seen him chasing a social
turtle trying to catch it in the water
and they've atom attack me on water I've
never seen a video of a gator eating
underwater before I mean you only see
really you only really see Gators
attacking stuff on land no they they do
it on a water bus it's not too many
people down there right exactly there's
not people down there you got to be down
there 24 night catching the feeding time
but they're eating fish let them right
down there they got to come up to
swallow it it's all underwater because
their throat locks down there didn't
want let water in their system desolate
control or else they can fill up a water
and drown oh sure so they just grab it
while they're down there then they come
up to the surface to actually eat it
won't see the Maples yeah
[Laughter]